to start it off I guess I'll just I'll
just um get myself in the hurt what
happens to us what happens I don't know
how to know you see this movie you enjoy
it so much that you go see it again and
again as many times as you possibly can
until you actually take in the detail
and realize that this is the end of the
Skywalker saga
I met me and you know absolutely we're
gonna speak even if I go on to another
franchise we speak this continues this
continues what getting tattoos next to
me she doesn't know it you're booked it
okay dude we're gonna relive we're gonna
go down memory lane
this isn't me and you though this is
just you ah yes we're standing in this
very spot four years ago this is very
spot pretty much yeah yeah what was
going through my head was I'm gonna just
have to have some fun I can't wait to
see the movie with like members of the
public and I'm so scared but this is the
beginning to something really cool and
now I'm just there like while we outside
for let's go see the film I've changed
changed I mean you guys have been on a
hell of a press tour for three movies
weeks of interviews what's the number
one question you're tired of answering
but we can't really speak about the film
that's the best of thing so I guess I
guess is people just trying to get more
details but I'm glad that after this I
don't have to keep no secrets after this
is all done so I'm glad about that okay
if you had to give a superlative to
Oscar or Daisy or Oscar and Daisy for
the franchise I don't know best answer
best hair best smile
best charismatic individual Oscar Isaac
best forehead sized capacity with length
Daisy Ridley peanuts peanut peanut I
love you I love this area specifically
she will know what that means
what was your reaction on watching the
credits roll absolutely numb numb and I
just shaking and ready for the world to
just see this epic epic movie I can't
wait
[Music]